president Trump was interested in buying
Greenland and I heard that a lot of
people were making jokes I thought that
Trump was on to something and I thought
hey that could be a really good idea
let's give him the benefit of doubt so
great in fact that this past weekend I
decided to fly to Greenland on behalf of
the United States to make sure that the
purchase I left I left Wednesday night
and just got back I brought a camera
crew with me and it's going to be our
new Konan Without Borders special Conan
yeah I will say this who here has been
to Greenland see look you can't say that
about any other people don't go to
Greenland but I will tell you I went
there it's beautiful it's a beautiful
beautiful place the the people are
extraordinary they're really funny
they're really lovely and I've learned a
lot as I always do on these travel shows
here's just a very quick clip from my
visit to Greenland
okay Vivi this is a famous statue what's
going on here seize this mug love to see
that's the mother of the sea I see an
interspecies orgy son seal on bear on
woman on dude action that's what I'm
getting and then there's a cart down
here that's really been excluded from
the fun looking at he's not too happy
about it I walk alone I think Trump will
be more interested after he sees this
statue that's all I'll say
my theory is that Trump saw that statue
online it was like we gotta have it
anyway we had a lot of fun and we
learned a lot be sure to tune in for our
Conan in Greenland special airing next
Tuesday and find out if I was able to
make Greenland party United States that
was part of the idea all right